a non-profit is dealing with a crime
impacting its goal to help the homeless
here in the valley eight news now
reporter Mary Jane beliesza shares their
struggle
it's been several months since thieves
took the catalytic converter off of
Marcus's Duke's club kids in community
RV now he's stuck in this vacant parking
lot in the east side Valley Marcus Duke
is the executive director of Club Kids
Inc helping homeless families in our
community by delivering clothes toys and
toiletries but now he's unable to
complete their mission this is the
fourth time this has actually happened
our catalytic converter got cut off our
truck
and it's costing us an arm and a leg to
actually get it back on Duke says it
could be up to a thousand dollars to get
the mobile RV fixed the non-profit is
all volunteer and donation based making
it hard to come up with the cash every
time we go to the shop it seems like the
price goes up and it's a big truck so
it's kind of hard to really you know to
afford to replace that in a thousand
dollars plus there's so much we can do
with that money there's so much other
stuff we can do so many other people we
can help we want to see what we can to
prevent this from happening I understand
that the governor just passed the new
law and that's a great thing that means
catalytic converter possession is now a
crime and can be charged as a felony you
now have to be a dealer or car owner to
have one and scrap metal junk yards are
required to keep sale records to the
crooks out there man y'all guys you're
going to get caught so you know I'm glad
that the new laws are hopefully slow you
guys down